okay we're talking back we just beat by  the arch alleges decree all free folk  are now enemies of the imager Empire  somewhere in these woods  a caravan is transporting villager  prisoners to labor in far-off lands find  the caravan and stop the images well  there's no telling what correct will  doom will befall our villager friends  what should I be my guy  [Applause]  sir I'm looking for your care of it  they're [ __ ] mad  [ __ ]  that way  [Music]  all right so anyway no joke today with  happy  hello  [Music]  [Music]  these villages are free from the clasp  of the images all thanks to you  damn straight that pic looks so [ __ ]  dumb  thank Joe and Joe money in the next one  back out